I'm just a girl standing in front of you with full hair and makeup and the WrestleMania shirt from WrestleMania 2017
asking you to allow me to judge people that are very much better at fashion and lifestyle than I am
Oh no
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know now you know your life is different now
The Met Gala has gala-ed all over our goddamn faces and it's time to review the fashion
This is the red carpet fashion event to end all other red carpet fashion events and if you don't know
I love doing red carpet fashion reviews
so it's the perfect combination
if you're unfamiliar with the Met Gala
I also do not fully understand exactly what it is. It's the fanciest Outback Steakhouse of fashion
There are no rules and no one's right
I'm already stressed and excited
"ex-stressed"
that makes it sound slightly positive, or like a 90s hip-hop group
the theme of this year's Met Gala is
"Heavenly Bodies: Fashion and the Catholic Imagination"
I mean all of Catholicism is really just a figment of our imagination
Everyone can believe whatever the f*** they want to believe. I believe it's a good idea for me to talk about fashion
So we all make choices, some of them are mistakes
segue into let's talking about these red carpet Met Gala fashions!
So this theme obviously has direct connection to religion which is often a very polarizing or controversial
subject to be talked about and I have to preface this video
Because I have to now with the fact that
I admire everyone that shows up to an event like this in clothes that are
cumbersome and not meant to be worn on the human body.
There is no disrespect. No f***ing on anyone
This is just a very pure, optimistic review of the fashion circus that is the Met Gala
That's my dog groaning, but also, you know,
foreshadowing for how you're gonna react to this video.
So many people went to the Met Gala this year
And there are so many looks being served
It's a goddamn
all-you-can-eat buffet because the service is unending
I know I will probably not talk about someone that you want me to talk about or look at or review
so I tweeted out asking for you guys to send me some of your favorite looks
And there are so goddamn many that we're gonna try and fly through them
I mean some might say there are as many looks served as there are indiscretions in the Bible,
Okay, I'm done
Liza Koshy. Liza Koshy is wearing this adorable
"Wednesday from The Addams Family got a makeover" outfit
And then wa-BAM it must be the Last Supper cuz she's serving rump roast right now,
And she looks great doing it. Good job Liza Koshy. Cute!
Shailene Woodley looks like a slightly uncomfortable, like, private school fembot
soldier that also models for like Space Abercrombie & Fitch. Cute!
Greta Gerwig
Why not? This is enough fabric to make like a full blimp, and this is like full Flying Nun, get it girl
this is like a
classy high-end
editorial nun Snuggie, and I'm here for it. Amen!
I gotta stop making those kind of, but I-I won't stop, I'm sorry, I can't stop.
Like Jesus! Oh wait he stopped
Cute!
Zoe Kravitz. Ooh! Let there be leg!
This is like the sexiest doily I've ever seen
Troye Sivan
Oh. My. God.
Christ has died, Christ has risen, and guess what Christ just came again because Christ has a huge crush on Troye Sivan and
looking at him in this outfit, ay-oh!
Who wouldn't come again?
I am really offending a lot of people. I'm sorry. I respect everyone.
Madonna. I mean this is just Madonna on a Tuesday this is Madonna
It's like she woke up and she checked her Evites and was like f***
It's the Met Gala
And then it was already sleeping in this and so just showed up
Janelle Monae can do no wrong to me at any red carpet
event ever, ever, ever and this included
Like a glamour Crusader that was fighting for like the right side of history and then was like, s***!
I need to get my Prince/Celine Dion backwards tuxedo thing, but wear it frontwards and get to the Met Gala
Keep my chainmail, just keep the chainmail. I don't want to worry about my hair. I love it
Bella Hadid
Bella How-did you get into that
ensemble? Good job. Cute!
Lana del Rey and Jared Leto.
You guys look like two tarot cards
And I'm here for it
70s Dumb and Dumber tuxedo situation meets a bird-emic meets "why the f*** not"
Cute!
Sarah Michelle Gellar and
Andy Cohen
if you don't know, go to the Met Gala every year and
Sarah Michelle Gellar is like the queen of the Met Gala
she always shows up with looks, and yeah, she
Wow
Alice in Wonderland meets the actual
Vatican meets Big Ben meets like sexy Hugh Hefner Matador chic, and why not yeah
This is decadent and subtle. So subtle. Cute!
Emilia Clarke from Game of Thrones. I love this. I love you
I mostly love photos of people fixing elaborate outfits on fashion carpets
So I really appreciate this on a lot of levels
You know it took a lot of "zhuzhing" like this to get that photo of the Last Supper so
a little behind the scenes inside scoop
Cute!
Jaden Smith you will always be seated at the right hand of his father.
When you think about it, Jesus was all about grassroots promotion
He was just in the streets screaming about all the things that he could do so
Jaden Smith okay, look. Brought his own Bible. It seemed to work. There's a pretty big following for Jesus
So if he did it, look, you could do it too
Ariana Grande
You look like the Sistine Chapel
Sis-you-look-like-a-teen Chapel. This is like a work of art
I also love that in every photo of
Ariana on the carpet her posture is so
demure it's as if she's either
channeling her inner, like, goddess or
the bow on her head somehow got tucked into. like, her thong,
and she literally cannot lower her chin either way got it, g-got it. Cute!
Donald Glover. I mean the Lord and Savior himself is there and needs no review
He's perfect and divine and hopefully going to save all of our dirty
souls. Cute!
Blake Lively. Wow! Amazing that she wore the tablecloth from the Last Supper to the Met Gala
Totally on theme, love it, and also
How did you get anywhere? The Met Gala happens in New York. I can't even like get myself in and out of a cab
with just my backpack on. How? What? Also you could spill red wine all night
And it's not gonna matter so, perfect color choice. Cute!
Nicki Minaj. Wow.
Also your face looks like you just found out that your dress has pranked you
and you didn't realize that it was this big the whole
time you're on the carpet, but whoa.
I mean this is really the body-ody-ody of Christ
Zen-day-a, Zen-die-a
I've always f***ed up pronouncing your name
But I am Zen-dead-a because this is f***ing awesome!
Chainmail, soldier, glamour, Joan of Arc.
You've single-handedly
rebranded what we've all come to hate that is chain mail.
You've got chain mail and god dammit
I wish I did too, Jesus Christ! Cute!
Katy Perry another very subtle moment at the Met Gala
You guys wanna know what Victoria's Secret is?
She's Catholic
And this is the reason the Met Gala is as dumb and fun as it is.
How did you get out of your car?
How did you get into the event?
Do you guys see any photos of Katy Perry like awkwardly trying to get in and out of
doorways
because of this outfit?
Please let me know
It's like when you see someone that goes to, like, a Comic Con and their dress is, like, Megatron or like,
you know
that's all I know
and their cosplay is super fucking impressive?
But then you watch them, like, try to handle, like, three stairs, and it's very very
Humiliating
I mean how she's even sitting like this is nuts. Plus,
this reporter's face
is pretty f***ing great
Kim Kardashian. The Kardashians in general are a powerhouse at the Met Gala
and this is pretty, you know, subdued for Kim.
Maybe that's the point
I don't know, I miss the days of sofa Kim.
Some might say I'm "sofa-Kim sad"
that we don't have those Met Gala days anymore. Cute!
Cardi B
my
God!
Literally you are my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god
[In awe of Cardi B]
I'm truly having a religious experience. This is amazing. I love everything about this. It's like if the Pope
transitioned and then got married this would be his wedding dress, and I f***ing love it
The Olsen twins
Honestly, I do not believe that this photo is from this Met Gala
This could be from any red-carpet event that they have been to at all in the last 10 to 15 years
Can't mock a smock! Cute
Ri-hanna
the Pope has arrived
[Stunned to silence at our lord and saviour rihanna]
Bless us O Lord for these thy gifts, which you're about to receive from thy bounty through Christ our Lord
A-men!
Jesus Chri- made a Pope hat look great!
Know what, I Vati-can't handle this and I've got a confession is it
Apostle-ble to look
this good? Cute!
Frances McDormand, I love this woman so much.
This is probably very on-theme
I don't f***ing know how or why, but I want her to wear this to every goddamn award show every event
This is her face
Protip: you don't have to worry about your hair and makeup if you go to an event dressed up like you're mid confetti cannon. Gahd!
She's so much better than all of us
Lena Waithe. Holy s***. This is so good
I just love everything you are and everything you do. Cute!
Diane Kruger. Wow, this is like Vatican-level toilet paper stuck in the back of the pants. Cute!
Hailee Steinfeld, "Steen-field", strn, stn, stnrn, Hielie Stnf
This is very like, "if Jesus had a stepdaughter, and it was her goddamn super sweet 16." Get it girl!
Chadwick Boseman
[Again stunned into silence due to Chadwick Boseman's perfection]
If we want to talk about God's gift,
I mean this is God's gift
so
Cute!
Okay guys that is my Met Gala fashion review
I know I
missed a ton of people that you might have wanted me to talk about but
leave comments down below who your favorite look was
there are so many
If you liked this video give it a thumbs up and do not forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel
I'm trying to post a couple videos a week.
We'll see how it goes
Y'know, nothing in life is certain
Jesus said he was coming back. Okay, gotta stop this. I don't know
J-Lo. Yes, yes yes yes
Yes yes
You look like a goddamn stained-glass window in some old-ass church in Europe
and then somehow like a
black bear burst through it
And if that isn't what Catholicism is I don't know what is. Cute!